[Music]  one of the uh most anticipated movies of  the year is the new batman film dark  knight rises and the movie has already  had some controversy because its main  villain bane or if you know about bain  that's the main villain  will fans have seen an early trailer and  the fans who've seen the trailer  complain that bain's dialogue is very  hard to understand  and they've complained about it but the  director thinks that bain sounds just  fine so he doesn't want to change it  now i have to tell you i saw the dark  knight rises trailer a couple of days  ago i agree with the fans i think  there's a problem take a look  [Applause]  i'm sorry i can't really understand what  you're saying maybe take off the mask no  let's try this one more time  just slow it down  i  i  blur  what is going on  little help  does anybody here speak whatever this is  [Applause]